bonjour je suis marine beccarelli j'ai
travaillé sur l'histoire de la radio
nocturne en france de 1945 à 2012 si on
vous dit radio de nuit vous pensez
sûrement
allô macha c'est bien je viens vers vous
afin de rejoindre vos rêves sous les
étoiles
certains de vos désirs ou quelques-unes
de vos nostalgie macha béranger est en
effet le symbole français de la radio
nocturne pendant près de 30 ans sur
france inter entre 1977 et 2006
l'émission allô mâcha diffuse chaque
nuit les confidences d'anonymes qu'elle
encourage de sa voix grave mais la nuit
est propice au développement de bien
d'autres programmes radiophoniques
originaux d'une part les enjeux
d'audience sont moins forts qu aux
heures de grande écoute
mais surtout la radio et la nuit
s'accordent parfaitement la première
émission nocturne régulière et créé en
france en 1955 appelée route de nuit ce
programme est avant tout destiné aux
conducteurs nocturne afin qu'ils ne
s'endorment pas au volant depuis combien
de temps écouter vous la radio la nuit
existe au delà des routiers l'audience
nocturne est en fait beaucoup plus large
et diversifiée
elle regroupe les travailleurs de nuit
mais aussi des étudiants des
insomniaques des artistes des personnes
âgées ou des malades vous écoute parce
que je dors très mal et que je prends la
nuit la route de nuit pour moi c'est une
compagnie gm entend tout ce qui se passe
cette vie nocturne que j'ignorais en
somme
progressivement les programmes de radio
de nuit se diversifie et se multiplient
des émissions culturelles festives
apparaissent comme le pop club créé en
1965 sur france inter et qui existera
jusqu'en 2005 manquait un club le soir
un endroit ou à la maison de la radio de
la rtf à l'époque ça ne ferme pas les
portes à 8h du soir tout était un peu
mort et on voulait un endroit où les les
parisiens les jambes passage pourrait
venir les gens connus ou pas connus
savait qu'il trouvait un endroit qu'ils
ont chaud où il y avait de la musique où
il y avait de la lumière au milieu des
années 70 apparaissent les émissions
nocturnes de confidences d'anonymes dans
lesquelles les auditeurs appellent pour
se raconter
avant la création dalo macha sur france
inter europe 1 proposent déjà lignes
ouvertes de gonzague saint bris
[Musique]
plus tard dans les années 90 ce sont les
libre antenne pour adolescents qui se
développent une émission bien rosé ou le
dock joue le rôle du médecin sérieux je
suis tandis que de son côté dit foule
joue celui du copain à l'esprit paillard
je ne sais absolument pas comment réagir
et pour des mois vite doc il ya d'autres
jours de renvoyer dans la semaine et
puis un doute saint valentin la nuit
radiophonique a aussi été un espace
temps de création en particulier à
partir de la fin des années 70 dans les
nuits magnétiques sur france culture ou
sur les radios pirates la liberté et
l'expérimentation sont de mise
vous écoutez radio rire
[Musique]
bon sur l'art vous êtes à l'écouté de
radio vers sur 99 mégahertz comme tous
les soirs il est 22h30 vous vous
entendez donc radio vers quelle station
ni interdite ni autorisé aujourd'hui
pour des raisons économiques et parce
qu'avec les podcasts l' écoute de la
radio a changé il n'existe quasiment
plus de programmes de radio nocturne en
direct passé minuit ou une heure ils
sont remplacés par des rediffusions de
la veille ou de la musique enregistrée
pourtant l'univers de la radio nocturnes
continuent d'inspirer les imaginaires
désormais tous les samedis je serai
votre oreiller vous serez mon édredon et
pour varier les positions parfois même
je serai votre et de redon et vous serez
mon oreiller
[Musique]